[Musique]
319 millions c'est le nombre de masques
fournis par québec aux écoles primaires
et secondaires cette année au collège
regina assumpta dans ahuntsic
les deux mille deux cents étudiants
doivent le porter en tout temps et le
changer une fois par jour
on sait tout de suite intéressé au
recyclage parce que quand on fait le
calcul ça donne le tournis c'est un demi
million de masques pour notre école à
nous ça a été clair pour nous qu'il
fallait les récupérer lundi matin multi
recycle venait donc chercher les masques
utilisés au cours des dernières semaines
l'entreprise qui facturent 116 dollars
pour chaque boîte ramassé est l'une des
cinq compagnies proposé par recyc québec
pour la récupération des masques
ça commence en novembre on a eu des
demandes de clients qui nous demandaient
un option au que l'enfouissement pour
les masses
présentement on parle de 250 clients les
masques transite ensuite dans une autre
cour de la région avant d'être envoyées
dans cette usine de niagara falls dans
l'état de new york où ils sont incinérés
pour produire de l'énergie pour le
réseau électrique local est ce qu elle
jeu en vaut la chandelle selon en fait
actuellement non brûlés du plastique
pour faire l'énergie je trouve que c'est
une aberration sur le plan
environnemental c'est un option qu'on
offre à nos clients
puis quand à moi c'est une meilleure
option que l'enfouissement
les masques à usage unique sont faits de
polypropylène une matière plastique et
ils peuvent mettre jusqu'à 500 ans avant
de se décomposer christophe bancilhon
préfère encore payer pour l'option
offerte par multi recycle c'est mieux
que rien écouter si les choses évoluent
et qu'il ya d'autres solutions qui
seraient entre guillemets meilleur on va
se pencher dessus ça c'est clair
l'entreprise excellent polymère de
bromont offre une autre solution
les masques envoyé ici sont mélangés
avec d'autres produits de polypropylène
comme serre taille de couches la matière
est ensuite fondus filtré puis ressort
en multitude de petites billes de
plastique
cette résine peut ensuite être utilisé
pour fabriquer certains produits
un bac qui va demander dans les grandes
surfaces situées au québec fait fait de
100% dans votre esprit
les masques d'excel polymères sont
récupérés par go 0 un programme lancé
par médecin le principal fournisseur
d'équipements médicaux au canada dans
l'incapacité à bromont de recycler
environ 45 50 millions de masques par
jour
donc ça fait aucun sens de les brûler ou
de lait ou de les enfouir folle et
collecter l'argent c'est là mais les
clients de gauche 0 paie plus cher
150 $ la boîte de 1000 masques ou
l'équivalent de 15,5 par masse que
recycler cette partie qui est dédiée au
fonctionnement de nos zéros
il ya une petite partie qui est dédié
aussi aux projets de recherche d'autres
produits orphelins congo reste clé j'en
conviens que si dispendieux qu'elle sait
pas accessible à tous le vent nouveau du
prix le recyclage des masques québec
paiera des millions de dollars cette
année pour rembourser les institutions
publiques qui récupèrent leurs masques
moi je me demande si c'est vraiment
actuellement la priorité
environnementale de riscle et les
masques
il ya beaucoup d'écoles qui ont pas
encore de programme de récupération des
matières recyclables qui ont peu de
programmes de pour les matières
organiques
donc ça c'est beaucoup plus dommageable
que les simples masques con qu'on jette
aux poubelles avant la pandémie
même les hôpitaux ne récupérez pas les
masques recyc-québec complète une étude
environnementale pour dicter la voie à
suivre
une chose est sûre il y aura un après à
cette pandémie et les recycleurs ne
s'entendent pas sur l'avenir du
recyclage des masses
c'est là pour rester et puis on a des
clients eux des masques de procédures
utilisées ça hatton havas n'a pas
d'ennemi pendant la pandémie utilise
deux fois plus qu'après la pandémie pour
construire l utiliser on est sur une
vague la demande et l'offre qu'on répond
aux besoins mais c'est pas une industrie
à long terme trop compliqué et pas assez
payant dit robert gagné les efforts le
tonnage les volumes que ça prend c'est
trop gros pour être capable de faire de
quoi au niveau recyclage on espère
simplement que au début de l'année
prochaine on aura plus ce set
cette chose là à faire ce serait la
meilleure chose qui puisse nous arriver
après le nom de pandémie et milliard de
masques jeter aux poubelles
ce serait aussi une très bonne chose
pour l'environnement